s'il fallait une preuve supplémentaire
de la prépondérance des réseaux sociaux
dans la prise de décision politique
la voici un appel d'offres lancé par le
service d'information du gouvernement en
décembre a été pourvue à la fin du mois
de mars sur la fiche disponible sur le
site officiel des annonces de marchés
publics
la mission est définie comme cela
l'accord cadre a pour objet la
fourniture d'outils de social listening
et de mesure d'impact sur les réseaux
sociaux pour permettre aux gouvernements
de détecter analyser et mesurer les
préoccupations et attentes des
internautes vis-à-vis de son action en
particulier et de l'actualité en général
un contrat à deux millions huit cent
mille euros répartis sur trois
entreprises une française et deux
étrangères
le principe derrière la notion de
sochaux listening et d'obtenir des
données concernant les thématiques les
plus discutés sur les réseaux sociaux
ensuite vient le temps de l'analyse puis
de l'adaptation de la stratégie à
adopter en misant autant d'argent pour
mesurer l'état d'esprit des internautes
français
le gouvernement montre qu'il y accorde
une importance croissante
cet investissement a été dénoncé par des
représentants politiques tels que
nicolas dupont aignan le député de
l'essonne estimant même qu'il s'agit
d'une forme de contrôle des libertés sur
les plateformes numériques
rien n'indique concrètement ce que le
gouvernement fera des données
recueillies par les entreprises
missionné adapter son discours et son
positionnement peut-être censuré et
riposter
rien n'est moins sûr mais les
précédentes décisions de l'exécutif
concernant les réseaux sociaux ont de
quoi créer l'inquiétude
la controversée loi avia a beau avoir
été retoqué par le conseil
constitutionnel
un certain nombre de dispositifs se sont
finalement retrouvés dans le projet de
loi séparatisme et puis le premier
ministre déplore toujours l'anonymat en
ligne qu'il compare avec le régime de
vichy
rien que ça en dépensant du temps et de
l'argent pour sonder l'opinion en ligne
le gouvernement prend en tout cas le
risque de recevoir une visite
biaiser les réseaux sociaux n'étant pas
ce qu'on peut qualifier d'outils
représentatif de l'ensemble de la
société française
mais qu'à cela ne tienne la campagne
2022 sera connecté ou ne sera pas
d'ailleurs le tournant 2.0 a déjà
commencé puisque à défaut de
journalistes à l'ancienne
le gouvernement se tourne de plus en
plus vers les influenceurs et les
youtuber pour la plupart plus malléable
afin de diffuser la bonne parole